ÐÏ à¡± á > þÿ B E þÿÿÿ C ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿì¥Á
q` ð ¿ u bjbjqPqP 4& : : u ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ
¤ ê ê ê ê ê ê ê > D j j j j † ‚ Ð
ö ž ž ž ž ž y
y
O Q Q Q Q Q Q $ Æ h . Ü u ê + y
+ + u ê ê ž ž Û Š › › › +
ê ž ê ž O › + O › › ê ê › ž
’ ð÷Q«ÓaÊ j 5
› O  0 Ð ›
? R
›
ê › ´ y
> ·
, › ã
$ $ y
y
u u ‘
Ð + + + + ‚ ‚ ‚ „ d ‚ ‚ ‚ þ
$ " : ê ê ê ê ê ê ÿÿÿÿ >> Welcome
Chris.
>> CHRIS: Hello.
>> I’d like to join you here at Google I/O?
Can you give us a brief introduction of your
company please?
>> CHRIS: Sure, well, my name is Chris. I
work at a company called NOREX, which is in
Halifax in Nova Scotia, Canada. We do a lot
of standard Websites. We’re starting to
get into Google App Engine type Apps and integrating
contacts, documents, and using different Google
APIs to make the customer experience the people
that are using our Apps a little more seamless
with their existing contact list and existing
documents.
>> Sir, can you talk to us about the features
of the contacts APIs, please.
>> CHRIS: Sure. The application we’re building
right now is basically taking the Contacts
API and adding a little bit more rich metadata
to that, so, it’s a CRM Map and so, we might
have other things associated with these contacts
and customers. The contacts can be turned
into customers which would have projects or,
you know, milestone associated with them.
So, we’re taking those contacts and keeping
them in sync with the Google contacts and
moving data back and forth in between the
two, but also adding richer metadata on the
App Engine side of things.
>> So, what are your favorite features of
the Contacts API?
>> CHRIS: One of the things I really like
about it is that you got a really full set
of data back from Google, so, you're not limited
to one email address, one address, one phone
number, you can add all sorts of other data
to it. Then, you can say that this a work
phone number, this is a, you know, a home
address. So, you got a whole bunch of other
information about them. You have notes filled;
you have all that sort of stuff. So, yeah,
it’s one of the things that has helped us
and we can actually take some of our metadata
and maybe it gets turn into a note and put
on the—on to the Google contacts where there
wasn’t a note before.
>> If you had any suggestions for the Contacts
API, what were some of—one or two things
that you’d like to see?
>> CHRIS: Not too much for the Contacts API,
one of the things I notice though was for
0xAB or client login, for actually getting
access to that data, is the process is a little
convoluted only because there are so many
different types of logins, there's a standard
GMail logins, there's a Google Apps for Domains
logins. The documentation was a little confusing.
It was all there once you dug deep enough,
but it was a little confusing to begin with.
On how, you know, I don’t want access to
my GMail contacts, I want access to my AdNorex.CA
contacts. So, getting that level of detail
from the documentation and from the code was
a little confusing at first, but we finally
worked around it, but yeah, that was one of
the kind of gauches that we initially had.
>> So, speaking of security, what security
are you using, a lock or OxAB?
>> CHRIS: We’re using 0xAB. It’s just
vanilla 0xAB really. It’s just a, you know,
standard token, it gets upgraded to a session
token and saves so that the user doesn’t
have to go back and, you know, re-authenticate
every time they use it. So, it’s pretty
vanilla 0xAB.
>> And you’ve also mentioned, you’re using
the Dotless API, how are you using that with
App engine?
>> CHRIS: Yeah, we’re just starting to be
that—to be honest it’s—so, for the CRM
Map that we’re just starting to write here,
they might have contracts or, you know, spreadsheets
or other documents that might need to be associated
with the project or the customer or what need
be. So, just to explain that, the list of
document associated with, you know, with the
person, yeah, it’s kind of how we’re using
it.
>> What are your favorite features of Dotless
API?
>> CHRIS: We haven't really used it that—in
depth, but mostly, I’ve been focusing on
the Contacts API. So far, I mean, the big
wind is that you can take a list of documents
associated with, you know, a model and, you
know, say it here, this is the contract, you
know, if you can go and edit that or if you
would print it off and do whatever.
>> And do you have any feature request on
the Dotless API?
>> CHRIS: I’m not sure that I do. One of
the talks I went to this morning, they were
talking about exporting and that sort of thing.
That was a pretty cool talk. One of the things
I’d like to see that you can work around
right now, is you can kind of, you know, a
PNG or JPEG preview of the document, which
you can work around by exporting as a PNG
and that kind of thing. But it would be really
great if, you know, in the XML that you return
if you had a link to, you know, this is a
thumbnail of what this document looks like.
>> Great. Well, thanks, Chris. And we wish
you well here at Google I/O.
>> CHRIS: Thank you.
& 2 6 ; N P g Œ À Â Ò Ö å è $ % Z [ Ã
È â ã Õ
Ö
! & k o ª ³ ´ µ ¸ Ò ã ä ô ÷ ¢
Á
V s t € ß ã ù ý ~ € ‚ › + , 2
< ] } ® · ùõñíéíéåéåíáåíáíÝíáíÝíáíÝíåíÝíáíÙÕáÕÙÕÑÕíÕÑÕáÕÙÕÑÕÑÕÑÍÕáÕÉÕáÉáÕáÕáÅáÁÍÁÅÁ½
hça hõI¨ h†;4 h°$ hÌ7z hä& hÐ;ì
hâ
h›\} h4 º hÂx h h5I= hÃy h 8& héP hQJ€
J # 7
ƒ
µ ñ t ä â , = ¡ < o Æ ` u ú ú ú ú
ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú ú
ú ú gdÃy u ý $ ( | ƒ ‘ ¡ À É Ê
Ë á â î
' + 6 B C S T [ \ ½ Ç ø ù / 0 7 8 < = ? @ W
Y h l t Ÿ æ õ ( , 7 : b j m š ›  ¡ È
É 8 : | Ž ˜ › ž ­ ± ´ ¹ » É üøüøüøüôüøðøüìüèüèäðèüàôàðàôàðàäàðàôàüàðàðäÜØàØàÔàÐàÌàÌÐàÈÐÈÐàÔàÈàÈàÔÈÔÐÈÐÈÐà
h¡ • h¼Kò h# Ò hz[Ò h†[Ú h Pp h8G«
h3 ¥ hÌ7z hÐ;ì h fE h4 º hça hõI¨
MÉ ô ü ! $
Y ] f ‹ 4 8 u üøüôüøüøüðüìüìüðüðüðü
hz[Ò h
T÷ h8G« h¡ • h=.
2 1 h :p Iù °Ð/ °à=!°- "°- #  $  %° °Ð
°Ð Ð † œ @ @ñÿ @ N o r m a l CJ _H
aJ mH sH tH D A òÿ¡ D D e f a u l t P a
r a g r a p h F o n t R i óÿ³ R T a b l
e N o r m a l ö 4Ö
l 4Ö aö ( k ôÿÁ ( N o L i s t D Z@ ò
D éP
P l a i n T e x t CJ OJ QJ ^J aJ u & ÿÿÿÿ
ÿÿ z™ ÿÿ z™ u Â # 7 ƒ µ ñ
t ä â
, = ¡ < o Æ ` w v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v%
û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1
v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1
v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 # 7 ƒ
µ ñ t ä â
, = ¡ < o Æ ` w ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € # 7 ƒ µ ñ t ä â
w š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € É
u u u ð8 ð @ ñ ÿÿ ÿ €€€ ÷ ð’
ð ð0 ð( ð
ð ðB
ð S ð ¿ Ë ÿ ? ð ÿÿ ½&‰ T¯# ¿&‰ $ Ü
À&‰ ¼ Ü Á&‰ Ä¿# ä ï ü ü w ë
ú w 8 *€urn:schemas-microsoft-com:office:smarttags
€City €9 *€urn:schemas-microsoft-com:office:smarttags
€place €B *€urn:schemas-microsoft-com:office:smarttags
€country-region €9 *€urn:schemas-microsoft-com:office:smarttags
€State € ìWw w w , 2 ® · Š ‹ 4 8
w w g å f Ãy =.
ïy â
éP ça W ä& Âx p °$ • C Nm! â0# Ô`$
8& 9' Ï$. †;4 ê 7 OB9 ¦8: • ; 5I= * D
fE ÔdJ á K ª5Q ° U Q V V ƒ8X
EX u
Y " \ ?ea `If Cff Pp “pq ÉKu v Ì7z ›\} úo
QJ€ ³+„ «S… Þ ‡ âS‡
z‰ ·6‹ Œ "Œ
WŒ ª,Ž ‹ Ö} ¡ • z ™ ¢qž í Ÿ
¯ ¤ 3 ¥ õI¨ 8G« š&¬ Lyµ 4 º p º
é ¼ Ð#Â º0Â )aÃ (mÊ U*Ï /?Ð # Ò
z[Ò P"Ø $Ù †[Ú W[á Í,ã * å é
ì Ð;ì $Xï fñ ¼Kò qXó pkó —Bô
T÷ Iù ?ú {ý ç þ kjþ ÿ@ € 4¯˜ u
` @ ÿÿ U n k n o w n ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ
ÿÿ ÿÿ G ‡z € ÿ T i m e s N e w R
o m a n 5 € S y m b o l 3& ‡z € ÿ A
r i a l ?5 ‡z € ÿ C o u r i e r N e w
" ñ ˆ ðÐ h …JÛ&ÁSÛF 0 ‚ ó F ‚ ó
F ! ð -  ´ ´ ~4 d ] ] 3ƒ ð HP (ðÿ
? ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ
ÿÿÿ "Œ 2 ÿÿ G > > C U T T S : W e h
a v e a g o o d q u e s t i o n f r o m M
a j i c o i n L o n d o n , U n i t e d K
i n g d o m p a r a m e d i x p a r a m e
d i x þÿ à…ŸòùOh «‘ +'³Ù0 ¸ ˜ è
ô 4 H T
t €
Œ ˜ ¨ ° ä H >> CUTTS: We have a good
question from Majico in London, United Kingdom
paramedix Normal.dot paramedix 28 Microsoft
Office Word @ ´ @ nâ
á`Ê @ ÓaÊ ‚ ó þÿ ÕÍÕœ. “— +,ù®0
T
p x ˜  ¨ ° ¸ À È Ð Ø
à 4 ä Arriba Telecontact Inc. œ F ] æ
H >> CUTTS: We have a good question from Majico
in London, United Kingdom Title
þÿÿÿ þÿÿÿ ! " # $ % þÿÿÿ' ( ) * +
, - þÿÿÿýÿÿÿ0 þÿÿÿþÿÿÿþÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿR
o o t E n t r y ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ À F x«ÓaÊ
2 € 1 T a b l e ÿÿÿÿ ÿÿÿÿ
W o r d D o c u m e n t ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ 4&
S u m m a r y I n f o r m a t i o n ( ÿÿÿÿ
D o c u m e n t S u m m a r y I n f o r m
a t i o n 8 ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ & C o
m p O b j ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ q ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ þÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
þÿ
ÿÿÿÿ À F Microsoft Office Word Document
MSWordDoc Word.Document.8 ô9²q þÿ à…ŸòùOh
«‘ +'³Ù0 ¸ ˜ è ô 4 H T
t €
Œ ˜ ¨ ° ä H >> CUTTS: We have a good
question from Majico in London, United Kingdom
paramedix Normal.dot paramedix 29 Microsoft
Office Word @ ´ @ nâ
á`Ê @ ÓaÊ } ã þÿ ÕÍÕœ. “— +,ù®0
T
p x ˜  ¨ ° ¸ À È Ð Ø
à 4 ä Arriba Telecontact Inc. h F a æ H
>> CUTTS: We have a good question from Majico
in London, United Kingdom Title † œ @ @ñÿ
@ N o r m a l CJ _H aJ mH sH tH D A òÿ¡
D D e f a u l t P a r a g r a p h F o n t
R i óÿ³ R T a b l e N o r m a l ö 4Ö
l 4Ö aö ( k ôÿÁ ( N o L i s t D Z@ ò
D éP
P l a i n T e x t CJ OJ QJ ^J aJ u & ÿÿÿÿ
ÿÿ z™ ÿÿ z™ u Â # 7 ƒ µ ñ
t ä â
, = ¡ < o Æ ` w v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v%
û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1
v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1
v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 v% û1 # 7 ƒ
µ ñ t ä â
, = ¡ < o Æ ` w ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0 € € ˜ 0
€ € ˜ 0 € € # 7 ƒ µ ñ t ä â
w š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š
0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € š 0 € € É
u u u ð8 ð @ ñ ÿÿ ÿ €€€ ÷ ð’
ð ð0 ð( ð
ð ðB
ð S ð ¿ Ë ÿ ? ð ÿÿ ½&‰ T¯# ¿&‰ $ Ü
À&‰ ¼ Ü Á&‰ Ä¿# ä ï ü ü w ë
ú w 8 *€urn:schemas-microsoft-com:office:smarttags
€City €9 *€urn:schemas-microsoft-com:office:smarttags
€place €B *€urn:schemas-microsoft-com:office:smarttags
€country-region €9 *€urn:schemas-microsoft-com:office:smarttags
€State € 0 w w w , 2 ® · Š ‹ 4 8
w w h å g çN Ãy =.
ïy â
éP ça W ä& Âx p °$ • C Nm! â0# Ô`$
8& 9' Ï$. †;4 ê 7 OB9 ¦8: • ; 5I= * D
fE ÔdJ á K ª5Q ° U Q V V ƒ8X
EX u
Y " \ ?ea `If Cff Pp “pq ÉKu v Ì7z ›\} úo
QJ€ ³+„ «S… Þ ‡ âS‡
z‰ ·6‹ Œ "Œ
WŒ ª,Ž ‹ Ö} ¡ • z ™ ¢qž í Ÿ
¯ ¤ 3 ¥ õI¨ 8G« š&¬ Lyµ 4 º p º
é ¼ Ð#Â º0Â )aÃ (mÊ U*Ï /?Ð # Ò
z[Ò P"Ø $Ù †[Ú W[á Í,ã * å é
ì Ð;ì $Xï fñ ¼Kò qXó pkó —Bô
T÷ Iù ?ú {ý ç þ kjþ ÿ@ € 4¯˜ t
u ` @ ` è4 @ ÿÿ U n k n o w n ÿÿ ÿÿ
ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ G ‡z € ÿ T i m e
s N e w R o m a n 5 € S y m b o l 3& ‡z
€ ÿ A r i a l ?5 ‡z € ÿ C o u r i
e r N e w " ñ Š ðÐ h …JÛ&ÁSÛF 0 } ã
F } ã F ! ð -  ´ ´ ~4 d a a 3ƒ ð HP
(ðÿ ? ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ
ÿÿÿ ÿÿÿ "Œ 2 ÿÿ G > > C U T T S : W
e h a v e a g o o d q u e s t i o n f r o
m M a j i c o i n L o n d o n , U n i t e
d K i n g d o m p a r a m e d i x p a r a
m e d i x ì¥Á q` ô ¿ u bjbjqPqP 4& : : u
ÿÿ ÿÿ ÿÿ ¤ ê ê ê ê ê ê > D j
j j j † ‚ à ö ž ž ž ž ž y
y
S U U U U U U $ Ö h > Ü y ! ê + y
+ + y ê ê ž ž Û š › › › +
ê ž ê ž S › + S › › ê ê › ž
’ °Öc¯ÓaÊ j 5
› S ° 0 à › ? R › ê › ¸ y
> ·
, › ã
$ $ y
y
y y ‘
à + + + + ‚ ‚ ‚ „ d ‚ ‚ ‚ þ
$ " : ê ê ê ê ê ê ÿÿÿÿ R o o t
E n t r y ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ À F °Öc¯ÓaÊ
G @ 1 T a b l e ÿÿÿÿ
W o r d D o c u m e n t ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ ? 4&
S u m m a r y I n f o r m a t i o n ( ÿÿÿÿ
è ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
þÿÿÿ þÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ6
7 8 9 : ; < = > þÿÿÿ@ A D ýÿÿÿþÿÿÿþÿÿÿH
F þÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
D o c u m e n t S u m m a r y I n f o r m
a t i o n 8 ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ „ C
o m p O b j ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ q 0 T
a b l e ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ 5 ÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
þÿÿÿ þÿÿÿ
þÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿÿ
þÿ à…ŸòùOh «‘ +'³Ù0 ¸ ˜ è
ô 4 H T
t €
Œ ˜ ¨ ° ä H >> CUTTS: We have a good
question from Majico in London, United Kingdom
paramedix Normal.dot paramedix 29 Microsoft
Office Word @ ´ @ nâ
á`Ê @ þÿ
ÿÿÿÿ À F Microsoft Office Word Document
MSWordDoc Word.Document.8 ô9²q þÿ ÕÍÕœ.
“— +,ù®0 T
p x ˜  ¨ ° ¸ À È Ð Ø
à 4 ä Arriba Telecontact Inc. h F a æ H
>> CUTTS: We have a good question from Majico
in London, United Kingdom Title ÓaÊ } ã